so just beware that statue office I want
you to recognize see how you've got
something square and then something I
learn a constant do to be made before
this is like a quadratic equation right
to make it really clear that it's a
quadratic equation I'm going to
introduce the substitution when you get
a little more comfortable with doing it
you don't have to do the substitution
you can actually solve it without
introducing new that is that let's just
work with it first I'm going to do this
contribution like this and now what
you've done is you have reduced the
problem to a quadratic equation to u
square minus 5p plus 2 you could almost
do that in your sleep so we call these
guys up here equations reducible to
quadratics bit of a mouthful I prefer to
call them quadratics in disguise so you
can solve that have a go and then if you
want to push in call me oh ha ha ha ha
I've just gone ahead to factorize and
now I have it in factorized form so at
this point if I were sewing for you I
would say u equals and there are two
days why don't you do a half or two very
good but I'm actually not solving for
you I'm solving for COD X right so I've
introduced my Constitution when are we
doing this a lot more in the future by
the way substituting something to make
something easier to solve but then
you're going to go back because the
original question has no use in it so
you've got to return to the original
term so now I'm going to say this is
actually two equations in cod X there's
this guy and then there's this guy okay
now we'll take it one at a time context
equal to hop again conveniently exact
tell you once the exact time it's 60
degrees and hopefully the cloud graph is
just ended up into your mind in your
life will sixties one of the solutions
there for 300 360 takeaway that is
another solution
so far so good then what do you do with
that guy you do with you any suggestions
yes does it work
now I there's lots of waves of these
very work for a job we might reach your
calculator and you put into your [ __ ]
garden and it says forget this go away I
can't do anything with that matter right
but the look which is why does it say
Matt Farah okay so what's the wait
reasons or ways to argue this on my
favorite way my preferred way is just
like we did here you think about what
the context crap looks like and you know
the end will choose the colors glad it's
your one to negative one I will wear it
to on this graph it's up here right
we're good so ill with codex and - they
just kind of do their own separate
things and they never are equal to each
other
so I would say from here no solution
okay it's actually I think important
that you recognize
you're not just ignoring method you're
not just looking at your calculator
saying I don't know about me but guess
I'll just not worry about it
you've actually recognized it and you
dealt with it you say it doesn't give
you a solution so therefore that's why I
conclude - one fun
therefore I'm saying even though I've
already written it here x equals 60
degrees for 300 only right that way only
there is my way of saying I've seen I've
seen it there a possible place
patrollers equate our solutions but they
don't give me any valid so that's why
these are only the solution that work
all right now let's just quickly finish
off because then only a couple more
tricks to learn
I won't even solve what was this but I
left all six for you I will just give
you one warning which is you see how
this side X on both sides there's
actually sine square it is a sign right
don't divide through by PI next don't do
it why not
Oh websites where you sign it why don't
you / time yeah you lose solution right
let me try to illustrate for you why
I'll just like we did here right five
times where that equals sine X is
actually a quadratic in the sky let me
show you what it would look like
that's what look like right now do you
see if I survived it through five you I
get this so that makes it which is this
and that is one of the solutions for you
you can put that anywhere but you've
missed another solution namely if you
come back here you could put in new
equal zero and it would still work right
except you've lost that solution because
you divided two by you remember when you
divide through by something introduced
or restrictions you said hey you better
not be dividing by 0 because that blows
things up except the thing you said with
the restriction was one of the solutions
so you lost it is gone okay so instead
of device you what should you do all
these on yeah you would take if you ever
design and then you can factorize you
enjoy himself in there okay now number
seven again not going so it for you a
wonderfully recognized go back to that
flowchart that this person assisting the
equation I showed you at the beginning
what piece of knowledge is seven drawing
on to ask you to solve it yeah I'm very
good if you remember the Pythagorean
identity then you can see there is a
version of it tossed away in this
question which version what do I divide
everything through by to get something
hopefully anywhere as divides you by
claude squared because that would you be
a tan squared plus one equals what's on
the right hand side
that guy right and you can see that guy
appears in your equation so you can
substitute this for this and then you
have any credit in obstructing hands and
you can solve it like we did disguise
which is just in close okay now last one
this one is actually worth writing down
because it's been a weird trip can you
write down the loss on point maybe on
the side so when you reach it you'll be
ready for it okay now I admit it looks a
bit read up and intimidating then the
previous lessons review looking at but
it actually is just like what you just
did about 30 seconds ago remember
Eric's book we said look this type of
going identity it'll help you out in
that question even though one is going
secondhand right but what you have to do
was from here to here you have to what
do we do you divide two by con squared
that turns something that wasn't useful
into something that want now have a look
at this and there was a double better
familiar but watch what happens if I do
exactly the same transmission right down
with me I'm going to buy this by cos
square and this by Chi square and this
icon squared I suppose I've been not
making feeling of deriving my contour -
all right so what what happens watch
have the first term size whatever cost
rate is just dance web by definition
okay now have a look in here this cause
and cancel with one of the cosines down
the bottom which leisure is three signed
on close which is 310 and then that last
guy there he just turns into two so you
can see so much of mathematics is
turning clutter problems Interpol's you
already recognize right well now you
recognize this problem you can turn out
that again
into a quadratic and ears and breakfast
okay so it's not charleen once you know
what to do